charles pasqua quant à lui entretient
savamment le suspense sur ses intentions
il a envoyé à tous les élus une pétition
pour l'organisation de fameuses
primaires dans la majorité candidat ou
pas candidat véronique saint-olivier
philippe deslandes ont suivi le ministre
de l'intérieur pendant plusieurs jours
pour essayer de savoir
charles pasqua qui est aujourd'hui une
position hautement stratégique au moment
où les trous balladurienne et
chiraquienne se met en ordre de bataille
le ministre de l'intérieur lui a fait de
se tenir à l'écart sa force ils veulent
éprouvé en ne faisant acte d'allégeance
à aucun des deux présidentiables et s'il
met chaque fois que l'occasion se
présente son poids politique dans la
balance c'est pour établir à son seul
profit un lien direct avec les français
cette confiance que souligner les
sondages charles pasqua l'a fait
fructifier puis les affaires empoisonne
le climat est plus ce capital devient
précieux
française inquiète charles pasqua par le
donc de sécurité tous azimuts et à la
majorité déboussolé il veut imposer une
autre forme de sécurité avec des
primaires la méthode pour gagner selon
charles pasqua je suis très loyal envers
edouard balladur que j'estime et avec
lequel
j'apprécie de travailler
quant à jacques chirac nous verrons bien
le moment venu quel est le mieux placé
pour le banc je ne me détermine qu'en
fonction de l'intérêt général l'intérêt
général c'est l'accord ait un seul
candidat de son bureau le ministre de
l'intérieur pèse et soupèse les forces
en présence on lui prête toutes les
intentions il n'en démord aucune alors
sera-t-il arbitres ou candidat pour
l'élection présidentielle charles pasqua
laisse monter les enchères mais il que
remarquée lui même que de la place
beauvau à l'elysée le chemin décidément
est bien court